vous avez été heureuse dans votre vie
très heureuse on a chanté
on a chanté et on le fait toujours
jusqu'à
[Musique]
la pointe du Finistère nord un chapelet
d'îles s'étend de la côte jusqu'à
Ouessant la Bretagne mythique c'est dans
le cas où des rochers des forêts des
eaux vives et des étangs ou régnait dans
l'imagination des hommes le roi Arthur
la fée Viviane et Merlin l'enchanteur
que nous la retrouvons
cette Bretagne là c'est le velgoat
vous avez toujours vécu non non pas
toujours non non
[Musique]
je suis revenu depuis 3 ans
où est-ce que vous étiez parti
je suis passé 12 ans en Amérique à New
York
je suis parti en 57
[Musique]
là j'ai 18 ans j'avais à peu près
à peu près 3000 verres d'écrit en
manuscrit tout en français ça me
contentait pas satisfaitait pas que je
pouvais pas écrire
autrement que le français j'ai arrêté
d'écrire
et puis je suis tombé sur des livres
écrit en breton j'ai appris à lire alors
par moi-même c'était relativement facile
puisque je connaissais la langue quoi la
langue parlé et étudié j'ai étudié donc
malin par moi-même et
finalement ça y est j'ai réussi j'ai
appris à l'écrire et depuis c'est
en breton j'écris des chansons aussi
depuis quelques temps je tourne même je
fais des récital enfin
rarement tout seul j'ai une équipe de
jeunes et vous avez un public
et curieusement un public que une grande
majorité de jeunes surtout les jeunes
des très jeunes votre respiration vous
la trouvez où ici dans dans les paysages
que vous côtoyez ou dans les légendes
qui sont les légendes du coin
c'est quand même
très important pour nous il y a pas
d'autres mais enfin
je pense que le monde où on vit
actuellement et très important et celui
que qui se prépare enfin je pense que
c'est ça qui compte
sur un rythme maghrébin que
nous contre l'histoire du breton son
travail qui quitte les mandarets pour
combattre dans les Aurès et qui de
retour ne trouve toujours pas d'emploi
pour faire un bon fermier
[Musique]
Amélie couette en noir pour faire mon
congé ta ce calma escouane dans les
monts de l'Orée ah la la la la
[Musique]
droite
bon boulot ma sculpture sur bois ça
c'est une vieille tradition bretonne la
sculpture sur bois tous les lits Claude
depuis le 16e le 17e siècle tous les
Bretons ce qu'ils le bois il y en a
encore un peu pas beaucoup passé non
plus
attirés par ça
les cercles folkloriques
c'est un peu péjoratif aujourd'hui le
folklore est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est du carnaval oui je vois ce que
vous voulez dire
propos des cercles folkloriques qui font
donc du carnaval c'est-à-dire qu'ils se
déguise périodiquement pour présenter
des danses un spectacle et Conques sur
un podium ça pour moi ça n'a aucune
valeur c'est du carnaval non un cercle
pour moi doit avoir un tas d'activités à
côté de ça d'activité culturelle il doit
il doit ils doivent étudier la langue
surtout mais ce qui se lance dans le
pays dans ce temps en costume
parce que ça se lance en costume si on a
l'habitude de porter le costume quoi
d'âme ou un bonhomme qui porte le
costume tous les jours il va pas quand
même se mettre en blue jeans pour pour
aller danser mais enfin le contraire
aussi si on a bu l'habitude de porter un
bloodyne on va danser on bloodyne ça
évidemment c'est on va danser pour son
plaisir quoi toutes les semaines partout
il y a des festounous dans un coin dans
un autre et alors là on retrouve donc
différentes générations tout le monde
danse et tout le monde a autant de
plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vous proposerait de vivre ailleurs en
France en Provence ou ailleurs
ça me dirait rien non
chez moi
[Musique]
convaincu au Finistère comme ailleurs
que le bonheur est dû au caractère de
l'homme plus qu'aux circonstances qu'il
traverse nous sommes allés dans le petit
village de saint-erbotte pour retrouver
d'autres gens heureux
depuis combien de temps ils ont
cultivateurs
je n'avais pas 15 ans quand j'ai quitté
l'école
comment c'était la vie et le travail à
la campagne à ce moment-là ah c'est
différent de ce que nous avons
maintenant alors tout le travail se
faisait
avec les chevaux puisque il n'y avait
pas de moteur ni de tracteur
les Brabants ont commencé
dans ma jeunesse avant que je ne parte
régiment mais avant ça non et on faisait
des journées de travail de combien
d'heures à ce moment-là
le plus long possible vous savez
oh oui le plus long possible on n'avait
pas l'électricité dans ce coin ici non
plus qu'est-ce que vous faisiez vous
comme travaux dans la ferme en dehors
à nourrir parce que tout ça c'était à la
main
vous avez été heureux pendant votre vie
oh oui oui oui je n'ai pas été
malheureux bien sûr loin de là
et comment on s'amusait à l'époque
je disais un jour il y a pas tellement
longtemps je les ai avec camarade mais
tu vois maintenant on ne chante plus à
la campagne puisque c'est le tracteur
qui a remplacé les chevaux et c'était
avec les chevaux qu'on chantait le matin
en allant chercher le trèfle et de
bonheur
le lever du jour bien sûr on allait
chercher et puis tout le monde chantait
dans les champs avec les charrues
suivant les chevaux tout le monde
chantait le soir c'était l'éveillé
on se rassemblait chez les voisins
tantôt chez l'autre on se rassemblait le
soir et puis la flambée dans la cheminée
alors comme on fait tous les soirs ici
encore même
tous les soirs on fait on fait du feu
dans le foyer qu'est-ce qui se passait
dans la veillée
si on est dans cette page une gavotte
c'est une chantait pas une gavotive
quand il y avait des
enfin on appelait ça les festonos de ce
temps-là quand il y avait un mariage ou
une fête quelconque après les journées
de travail également les fortes journée
travail par exemple la fenaison la
moisson les arrachages de pommes de
terre
on rassemblait tous les voisins enfin
des autres villages aussi même et puis
c'était la gavotte toujours et rien que
la gavotte
et tout le monde savait chanter
il y avait pas de télé il y avait pas de
choses comme ça ça fait qu'on était
obligé de chercher une distraction
c'est qu'on allait tout payer et vous
avez été heureuse dans votre vie très
heureuse on a chanté
et on le fait toujours
[Musique]